merci de votre présence à cette
commission
[Musique]
Messieurs les Ambassadeurs mes chers
collègues c'est un honneur de recevoir
ce matin Monsieur Alain Youssef
ambassadeur d'Égypte en France et
Monsieur Stéphane Crouzat ambassadeur de
France chargé des négociations sur le
changement climatique
tout d'abord permettez-moi de remercier
Monsieur Youssef pour sa présence parmi
nous je sais Monsieur ambassadeur votre
attachement au dialogue avec le
Parlement français et la disponibilité
dont vous avez super faire preuve ces
dernières années pour répondre aux
sollicitations du groupe d'amitié
france-égypte présidé par notre collègue
Catherine Morin de saillie nous nous
réjouissons naturellement de ce dialogue
régulier signe de l'étroite
collaboration entre nos deux pays la
présidence égyptienne de la Coop a
récemment détaillé ses priorités
rappelant sa volonté de faire de la COP
27 la conférence de la mise en œuvre de
l'accord de Paris
vous aurez l'occasion Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur de nous présenter les
principaux axes de travail qui seront
ceux de votre pays
je salue également monsieur Stéphane
crousat que notre commission avait eu le
plaisir
d'entendre l'année passée en amont de la
COP 26 vous aviez également accordé un
entretien à notre délégation présente à
Glasgow nous nous réjouissons de votre
volonté de rendre des comptes devant la
représentation nationale de l'avancée
des négociations climatiques
venons-en au coeur de notre réunion du
jour réunion qui portera sur les enjeux
bien entendu de la COP 27 un an après la
conférence de Glasgow dans son rapport
l'an dernier sur la cop26 notre
commission avait dressé un bilan pour le
moins contrasté des négociations d'un
côté Glasgow a maintenu la vie en ville
accord de Paris en parachevant ses
règles d'applications et en offrant aux
États un cadre propice un relèvement de
leurs ambitions climatiques
les États se sont notamment entendus sur
des règles d'application de l'article 6
de l'accord de Paris relatif aux
dispositif de marché qui doivent
contribuer à donner un prix suffisant
carbone pour accélérer la transition
l'accord sur les règles de transparence
devrait également permettre de mieux
comparer les contributions de chaque
État et de contrôler la réalité et
l'efficacité des actions entreprises
pour respecter ses contributions
la demande faite aux états de revoir et
de renforcer leurs feuilles de route
les fameuses contributions nationales
d'ici la COP 27 devait également
permettre de renforcer l'ambition
collective dès cette année 2022
plusieurs mois après Glasgow quel bilan
faites-vous de ces avancées en
particulier constate-t-on un relèvement
de l'ambition par le dépôt de nouvelles
contributions nationales comme le
prévoyait le pacte de Glasgow
ce relèvement de l'ambition collective
est indispensable rappelons que la somme
des engagements pré-à-glasgow plaçaient
la planète sur une trajectoire
d'augmentation des températures de
2,3 degrés centigrade dans le scénario
le plus optimiste
notre rapport sur la cop26 publié la
dernière constaté par ailleurs des
avancées largement insuffisantes en
matière de finances climatique qui nous
faisait craindre un accroissement des
tensions entre pays développés et pays
en développement au risque de paralyser
durablement la négociation climatique en
particulier la cop26 n'a pas permis de
trouver de solutions de financement pour
les pertes et préjudices
vertèbres correspondant au dommage
résiduel inévitable du changement
climatique en dépit des nombreuses
demandes des pays vulnérables
l'instauration du mécanisme de Glasgow
en joignant l'ensemble des parties
avancées en deux ans sur ces sujets de
financement avaient toutefois été perçue
comme une issue positive où en est-on
dans la mise en oeuvre de ce mécanisme
de Glasgow quel rôle la France et
l'Union européenne d'une part et la
présidence égyptienne d'autre part
peuvent-elles jouer pour faire avancer
cet aspect crucial des négociations
l'ambassadeur d'Égypte je vous donne la
parole je laisserai ensuite la parole à
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur cruzat répondre à
ses premières interrogations et la
parole bien entendu à mes collègues pour
vous interroger sur ces sujets merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs bonjour à vous
tous
il m'est particulièrement
agréable m'adresser
aux membres de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et de
développement durable du Sénat
ce bâtiment
emblami emblématique que je trouve
toujours de plaisir l'honneur de me
retrouver aujourd'hui avec vous et
partagez aussi notre vision pour la
prochaine copains
les questions de changement climatique
ainsi que les bilans escomptés de la
conférence
nous entamons des discussions courantes
avec nos collègues au Quai d'Orsay avec
qui je partage aujourd'hui
le la parole et avec qui aussi je suis
étroite collaboration chaque jour sur
les différentes questions qui vont être
discutées et évoquées durant la
prochaine cop
les relations bilatérales entre le cœur
et l’égypte et le carré Paris sont
stratégiques sur tous les niveaux c'est
ma deuxième visite au Sénat dans 15
jours j'ai accompagné le président de
Sénat égyptien dans une visite
officielle il a rencontré le président
l'archet et aussi les membres de la le
groupe d'amis
que je salue tous les membres et aussi
surtout Madame Catherine Morin de
saillie la présidente du groupe
Mesdames et Messieurs le monde de nos
jours fait face à des enjeux mon Dieu
consécutifs sans précédent la crise
énergétique à cause de la guerre en
Ukraine qui a aussi causé une crise
alimentaire les changements climatiques
les répercussions de covid 19 et enfin
le ralentissement économique et les
vagues l'inflation qui ont résultent
pourtant dans chaque défi se trouve une
opportunité et dans la cop27 il s'agit
d'une opportunité incontournable pour
converger davantage les efforts mondiaux
de l'action climatique et assumer notre
responsabilité à l'égard des générations
futures et protéger leurs droits de
vivre dans un environnement sain
mesdames dessinatrices monsieur les
sénateurs pour les changements
climatiques tous les rapports et les
estimations des différentes
organisations internationales et des
sens de recherche
ont clairement mis l'accent sur
l'importance majeure de la lutte
immédiate contre les changements
climatiques et la nécessité de la mise
en oeuvre sans retard de tous les
engagements internationaux c'est
pourquoi l'Egypte a choisi de nommer la
conférence d'un covd
ou plutôt le sommet de la mise en oeuvre
car nous estimons que maintenant c'est
les tons de réagir sinon tout retard ne
sera pas pour le prix de la l'humanité
l'Egypte attache une importance
particulière au modalités de passer de
la phase de l'engagement à celle de
l'implémentation et ces modalités sont
profondément discutées avec tous les
partenaires les gouvernements les
organisations internationales
la société civile le secteur privé et
tout autre
de fait que notre vision et que l'action
climatique est une responsabilité
commune de tous les acteurs
internationaux
permettez-moi de mettre l'accent sur
trois axes majeurs que l'Égypte vise à
prioritiser pendant la conférence à
savoir le financement du climat
l'adaptation avec une concentration sur
le thème des pertes et des préjudices
ainsi que la mitigation ou l'atténuation
le financement climat est de prime
abordent la pierre angulaire de la
coopération internationale pour l'action
climat en 2009 les pays développés se
sont engagés apportés à 100 milliards de
dollars par an l'aide au pays on voit de
développement en faveur du climat
pourtant 13 ans plus tard les bilan
final n'a pas reflété des bonnes
intentions et les estimations les plus
optimistes montrent que juste 79% de ces
engagements sont honorés même si on
atteint le but de 100 milliards de
dollars chaque année cela ne couvre
selon des experts que 3% de la valeur
demandée pour relever ces deux filles et
qui estimait entre 2,2 et 3,5 trillions
de dollars et là je voudrais saluer les
efforts inlassables de la France cet
égard qui est devenu un des principaux
bailleurs internationaux finançant le
climat avec
26,4 milliards d'euros de financement
approuvé pour le climat depuis 2017 ici
milliards de dollars
pardon et 6 milliards d'euros pour
l'année 2021 dans les pays en
développement selon les données la FD
l'Egypte vise donc à mettre en œuvre
d'initiative applicables pour le
financement innovant de l'action
climatique à travers des instruments de
nature à ne pas alourdir le fardeau
dépliant développement comme les
échanges de dettes par exemple en
coopération avec les institutions de
financement international les bailleurs
de fonds et le secteur privé
a de même organisé en septembre dernier
la conférence de la coopération
internationale dont l'objectif principal
était d'assurer la cohérence de position
en matière de financement climatique et
de présenter les pratiques de
développement réussie
et de défendre les nouvelles initiatives
de financement réalisables sur la
mitigation et l'adaptation
on outre une des journées thématiques
organisée en marge de la cop27 et
consacrée aux financement on regroupant
des ministres de financement des
représentants des institutions des
financements international et régional
et les secteurs privés afin de discuter
les questions globales liées au
financement surtout dans les pays en
développement et le rôle important du
secteur privé dans l'action climatique
pour la motivation ou quelquefois on
l'appelle la tuniation l'Egypte
œuvre à unifier les efforts
internationaux lors de la conférence
pour limiter le réchauffement climatique
bien au-dessus de 2 degrés et n'est pas
épargné aucun effort pour maintenir
l'objectif de 1,5 degrés le secrétaire
général de l'ONU a averti lors de la
dernière assemblée l'inauguration de la
dernière de la récente assemblée
générale en septembre 2022 que
l'objectif de 1,5 degrés et sous
respirateur artificiel
et faiblit rapidement
cela exige des actions immédiates et
audacieuses est une ambition accrue de
la part de tous les partis
la cop27 sera donc l'occasion pour tenir
les promesses et les engagements on vit
atteindre les objectifs de l'accord de
Paris et stimuler sa mise en œuvre
d'autre part tous les pays sont invités
lors de la cop27 dans le cadre du pack
de glacego comme vous l'avez bien
mentionné monsieur président à revoir et
renforcer les objectifs dans leur
contribution déterminée au niveau
national les CDN on les appelle je
voudrais signaler à ce point que
l'Égypte a présenté en juin dernier son
rapport national qui reflète l'ampleur
de l'ambition dans les mesures que
l'État s'est engagé à mettre en œuvre
jusqu'à 20 30 dans les domaines de
rénergie renouvelable le transport le
financement d'air etc sur l'adaptation
les événements météorologiques
telles que les vagues de chaleur ils
inondations et les incendies des forêts
sont devenus une réalité quotidienne de
notre vie
les chefs d'État et de gouvernement ont
réitéré leur engagement lors de la Coop
26 pour un action mondiale renforcée sur
l'adaptation la cop27 se tient donc à
exhorter toutes les parties à faire
preuve de la volonté politique
nécessaire pour renforcer la résilience
des communautés les plus fragiles à
s'adapter avec les changements
climatiques la cop27 devrait également
être témoin d'un programme d'action
mondial renforcé pour l'adaptation
confirmant ce que nous avons convenu à
Paris et précise et préciser dans la
dans le pacte de Glasgow en faveur du
placement de l'adaptation au premier
plan de l'action mondiale
le dossier épineux des pertes et des
préjudices reste toujours sur le table
de négociation de la cop27 surtout que
tous les pays soient développés où on
voit développement dans les quatre coins
du monde sont touchés par les effets
désastreux des changements climatiques
et subissent par conséquence des coûts
économiques très lourds
la présidence de la cop27 c'est engagé à
mettre en œuvre les engagements déclarés
lors de la conférence de Glasgow sur
l'accélération des mesures liées à
contenir les pertes et les préjudices du
climat surtout le financement le
transfert des technologies et le
renforcement des capacités
tous ces axes ont été profondément
discutés lors des réunions de pré-cops
qui sont tenus à Kinshasa la semaine
dernière
ces réunions ont remis l'accent sur
plusieurs priorités de l'action climat
parmi lesquels la nécessité de trouver
des nouvelles des nouveaux outils de
financement pour les pays le plus
vénérable tout en mettant en
considération la particularité de chaque
pays et ses besoins
mesdames les sénatrices monsieur les
sénateurs on a organisant cette
conférence sur des territoires
africaines l'Egypte vise à faire écouter
la voix de l'Afrique et se préoccupation
légitime
l'Afrique bien que responsable de 3%
seulement des émissions mondiales et le
continent le plus touché des changements
climatiques et le plus vulnérable à les
confronter les indicateurs climatiques
sont caractérisés par une augmentation
continue de température une accélération
de l'élévation de niveau de la mer des
phénomènes météorologiques et
climatiques extrêmes tels que les
inondations les glissements de terre de
terrain les sécheresses et ses impacts
dévastateurs sur la paix et la sécurité
ça ajoute à cela que 500 millions
d'Africains ne possèdent pas aucun
source d'énergie alors que presque 900
millions n'ont pas accès à des
combustibles de cuisson propre
le coût de l'adaptation s'élève à 2% de
PIB africains sont mentionnés le fardeau
de dettes qui est fait le coup largement
plus lourd
c'est pourquoi
l'Egypte va lancer pendant la COP 27
initiative compréhensive ont autre de
nature à réaliser l'accessibilité rapide
et juste aux sources d'énergie pour 300
millions d'Africains d'ici 2027
pour l'Egypte l'action climatique
occupe une priorité sur l'agenda du
gouvernement et à l'adopte sur le plan
local une approche compréhensive pour le
développement vers afin de permettre de
contribuer plus efficacement à la lutte
contre les changements climatiques en
parallèle avec ses efforts à diversifier
ses sources d'énergie tout en se
reposant plus en plus sur les ressources
renouvelables
l'Égypte a lancé à titre d'exemple la
stratégie énergétique durable intégrée
20 tranches qui vise à produire 42% de
son électricité à partir de sources
renouvelables d'ici à vins 35 d'autre
part l'Égypte se dirige de plus en plus
vers le projet de moyens de transport
vers de nombreux sont en collaboration
des compagnies françaises afin de
diminuer les émissions carboniques le
gouvernement offre en outre des
facilités accrues qui arrivent jusqu'à
l'exemption totale des frais de douane
pour l'importation des véhicules
électriques et la baisse des tarifs sur
les véhicules hybrides
et dans le et dans la presse respective
de localiser l'industrie des véhicules
électriques l'Egypte a signé un miroir
d'entente avec un groupe française très
connu afin de promouvoir la coopération
avec cette gigantesque entité
mesdames Messieurs le sénateur pour
conclure la réussite de la cop27 et la
responsabilité de tous
et nous n'avons pas le luxe de choisir
autrement l'Egypte n’épargne aucun
effort pour que la conférence puisse
reprendre aux ambitions de tous les
peuples du monde qui comptent sur nous
gouvernement organisation internationale
parlementaire bien sûr secteur privé et
la société civile pour garantir à nos
futurs générations un meilleur avenir où
ils peuvent répondre à leurs besoins en
paix en prospérité je remercie
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur oui
effectivement on est tous concernés
messieurs les sénateurs c'est un plaisir
un honneur de d'être présent parmi vous
pour évoquer cette importante échéance
qui nous attend d'ici moins d'un mois
maintenant à la COP 27 plaisir aussi
d'être avec l'ambassadeur Youssef avec
qui nous entretenons des relations très
étroites nous sommes vus pas plus tard
qu'hier pour évoquer la venue du
président de la République à la cop27
qui donc dont vous savez qu'il y aura un
segment des leaders en début de Coop les
lundis et mardi 7 et 8 novembre et et
donc le président de la République a
manifesté son souhait de participer aux
côtés de plusieurs dizaines de chefs
d'État et de gouvernement à cette très
importante échéance
baptisé comme vous l'avez rappelé la COP
de la mise en oeuvre alors peut-être
quelques mots sur ce que nous nous
voyons comme étant les
l'enjeu de cette coque autour peut-être
des quatre grands piliers de la
négociation que seront l'atténuation
l'adaptation les pertes et préjudices et
les finances qui sont en toile de fond
de l'ensemble de des discussions puisque
les questions financières surgissent
dans toutes les salles de négociation
sur sur tous les sujets
peut-être d'abord sur l'atténuation
rappelons
rapidement où nous en sommes
l'année dernière en 2021 nous nous
avions collectivement le monde entier
est mis plus de 52
gigatonnes de de gaz à effet de serre je
rappelle que au moment de la de l'accord
de Paris en 2015 nous étions à 45 46
gigatonnes donc depuis
l'accord de Paris nous avons
effectivement augmenté nos émissions et
non pas réduit nos émissions et nous
sommes toujours dans une phase
ascendante c'est à dire qu'on doit s'a
en 2022 à ce que nous augmentions encore
collectivement nous l'ensemble des pays
du monde nos émissions
ce qui est assez inquiétant puisque je
rappelle que le GIEC nous exhorte à
diminuer nos émissions de manière
urgentes pendant cette décennie critique
qui est la dernière fenêtre
d'opportunité pour que nous puissions
rester sur une trajectoire du bas de la
fourchette de l'accord de Paris je
rappelle que l'accord de Paris prévoit
une augmentation de la température entre
1,5 et 2 degrés maximum et nous espérons
pouvoir rester au plus proche des 1,5
degrés et pour pouvoir rester au plus
proche d'ici 1,5 degrés le GIEC nous dit
qu'il faudrait que nous réduisions nos
émissions de 43% pardon de 45% de nos
gaz à effet de serre d'ici 2030 par
rapport à 2019 pour l'instant donc nous
en sommes loin
et il y a beaucoup d'efforts encore à
fournir alors
Glasgow avait pris la mesure de cette
urgence avec des décisions fortes sur
les questions d'atténuation en
particulier
dans l'arsenal de mesure sur le fait que
les parties qui ne seraient pas qui
n'auraient pas soumis des contributions
déterminées au niveau national qui sont
en ligne avec cette trajectoire de 1,2,5
degrés d'augmentation devrait
revisiter et renforcer leur CDN avant la
fin 2022
prévoyez aussi que le rapport de
synthèse du secrétariat de l'acnuque qui
fait un bilan de l'état des CDN serait
désormais annuel prévoyez aussi une
table ronde ministérielle annuelle pour
pour garder ce sujet au niveau politique
et exercer une sorte de pression
collective sur des pères sur l'ambition
près 2030
encouragement aussi à soumettre des
stratégies de long terme pour toutes les
parties ce qui est encore loin d'être le
cas et la constitution d'un programme de
travail sur l'atténuation qui devra être
finalisée pour cette décennie 2020
jusqu'en 2030 à la COP 27 et c'est un
des livrables que nous attendons de la
COP 27 de Charm el shake
alors est-ce que les partis ont écouté
ces exhortations pour l'instant nous
avons à ce jour 23
partis qui ont soumis une CDN renforcée
revisitée l'Egypte ont fait partie
félicitations
[Musique]
mais d'autres pays des très grands
émetteurs je pense en particulier à la
Chine n'a pas soumis cette année une
contribution nationale revisitée et
renforcer alors tous les regards se
tournent évidemment vers les pays du G20
le G20 je rappelle représente
pratiquement 80% des émissions mondiales
et c'est donc une enceinte absolument
décisive pour
pour faire en sorte que l'effort
collectif soit à la mesure de l'enjeu
les choses
se sont pas bien passé disons-le à la
ministérielle G20 de la fin août qui
avait lieu à Bali vous souvenez que le
31 octobre avait lieu cette
ministérielle
climat environnement pour laquelle nous
n'avons pas réussi à trouver un accord
sur un communiqué pour plusieurs raisons
la première raison c'était la
qualification de la guerre d'agression
par la Russie en Ukraine en présence de
la Russie c'était difficile d'avoir un
langage consensuel sur cette question
dont nous savions pratiquement d'entrée
de jeu que nous n'aurions pas un
en 2021
on s'est fait rétorquer que les
circonstances étaient particulières
cette année et que le mot de leadership
n'était peut-être pas approprié donc les
les discussions étaient très difficiles
et finalement n'ont pas pu aboutir nous
avons eu finalement un résumé de la
présidence qui n'a aucune valeur en
réalité puisque elle n'engage que que la
présidence et non pas les membres du G20
nous avons eu ensuite Kinshasa où j'ai
accompagné la ministre
Agnès panier rue naché qui dirigeait la
délégation française pour ou là les
conversations étaient je pense un peu
plus constructive
avec une soixantaine de délégations
menée en grande partie par des ministres
et qui a permis d'avancer sur les quatre
piliers que j'évoquais même si nous
n'avons pas fait avancer décisives au
moins les conversations ont été je pense
plus constructive et permettre d’augurer
d'une d'une cop27 un peu plus apaisée
que ce qu'on a pu connaître où j'ai 20
ou à bonne d'ailleurs en juin ou les
négociations négociations des
intercessions entre négociateurs avaient
été très tendu
donc voilà pour ce volet atténuation où
nous vraiment nous nous espérons et nous
ferons en sorte que les acquis de
Glasgow soient
conforté et renforcés puisque vraiment
nous devons absolument avancer sur cette
question je rappelle que l'Union
européenne est au rendez-vous vous savez
que nous avons déjà il y a deux ans
maintenant annoncés une augmentation de
notre ambition moins 55% au moins
55% de réduction
nette de nos gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2030 par rapport à 1990 c'était une
augmentation par rapport aux 40% que
nous avions décidé en 2014 je rappelle
aussi l'incroyable défi que ça
représente pour l'Union européenne
puisque nous avons fait 20% de réduction
d'émissions entre 1990 et 2020 grosso
modo et qu'il s'agit désormais de faire
35%, 20 + 35 = 55 5 en moins d'une
décennie d'ici 2030 donc le défi est
vraiment
extraordinaire mais nous nous donnons
les moyens de le faire puisque avec le
paquet fit for fifty-five nous avons
beaucoup avancé sous président
françaises pour mettre tous les outils
législatifs européens en place pour être
au rendez-vous de cette ambition et nous
espérons pouvoir conclure dans les
prochains mois en trilogue avec le
Parlement et la Commission
quelques mots peut-être sur sur les
autres volets de la négociation qui
seront
l'adaptation les pertes préjudices et la
finance je l'ai mentionnerai de manière
peut-être un peu groupée puisque dès
qu'on parle d'adaptation et de pertes et
préjudice on parle beaucoup de finances
je pense en particulier en matière
d'adaptation à la à ce qui a été indiqué
dans le dans le le pacte de Glasgow sur
le climat que le pacte exhortait les
pays développés à doubler leur finance
pour l'adaptation
2025 par rapport à 2019 alors ça c'est
une réponse à des demandes très simples
des pays en développement qui estiment
que le l'effort fait par les pays
développés pour aider les pays en
développement en matière d'adaptation
sont insuffisants
je rappelle les chiffres de la France
vous l'avez rappeler Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur et je vous en remercie 6
milliards de d'euros par an qui avait
été annoncé par le président de la
République à la fin de l'année 2020
jusqu'en 2025 dont 2 milliards pour
l'adaptation nous sommes au rendez-vous
de cette promesse puisque la France
vient de confirmer que nous avons
dépassé notre objectif de 6 milliards
pour l'année 2021 dont 2,2 milliards
pour l'adaptation 2,2 milliards pour
l'adaptation quand on voit les chiffres
de la finance mondiale pour l'adaptation
vous avez évoqué en effet le fait que
nous ne sommes pas encore au 100
milliards requis nous étions à 83,3
milliards de dollars pour la finance
climat au plan global de la part des
pays développés en faveur des pays en
développement selon le dernier rapport
de l'OCDE en 2020
donc c'est insuffisant mais le
l'OCDE indique également que nous étions
à 28 milliards sur ces
83,3 en faveur de l'adapte de
l'adaptation ce qui est une hausse assez
sensible par rapport à 2019 puisqu'en
2019 je rappelle les chiffres
79,6 milliards de dollars dont 20
milliards pour l'adaptation donc je
reviens à mon chiffre de 2,2 milliards
d'euros de la France pour l'adaptation
sur un total en 2020 de 20 milliards ça
veut dire qu'on est à peu près à 10% la
France seule est à peu près à 10% de
l'aide pour l'adaptation au plan mondial
en tout cas ce sujet sera certainement à
l'ordre du jour les pays en
développement nous demanderons des
comptes sur la manière dont nous
comptons y arriver pour que cette
trajectoire soit respectée ceci dans le
cadre de cette effort plus global que
nous avions sur lequel nous nous étions
engagés de 100 milliards de dollars par
an
d'ici 2020
nous n'y sommes pas encore nous nous
réfléchit nous nous regardons la
trajectoire et nous avons bon espoir
qu'en 2023 nous atteindrons les 100
milliards de dollars avec une
augmentation significative d'ici 2025 en
tout cas ce sujet sera sur la table et
beaucoup de pays développés
seront regardés de près sur les
engagements qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
souscrit ou
espérons les nouveaux engagements qu'ils
pourraient qu'ils pourraient faire vous
avez indiqué Monsieur l'Ambassadeur que
600 milliards c'est quelque chose en
effet très important c'est totémique
mais c'est loin d'être suffisant par
rapport aux besoins et il faut que nous
regardions ailleurs il faut que nous
regagnons sur la mobilisation des
investissements du secteur privé et là
nous y travaillons collectivement sur la
mobilisation des banques multilatérales
de développement qui peuvent aussi créer
des effets de levier très important pour
le développement de la finance climat
que ce soit pour l'adaptation ou pour
l'atténuation il y a aussi la question
des pertes et préjudices que monsieur le
Président Monsieur l'Ambassadeur vous
avez évoqué sujet extrêmement sensible
extrêmement important qui est monté en
puissance à la COP 26 comme vous le
savez avec des avancées quand même à la
cop26 sur le l'opérationnalisation du
réseau de Santiago sur le
la catalysation de l'assistance
technique pour la question des pertes et
préjudices il s'agit maintenant de
transformer l'essai pour faire en sorte
que vraiment ce réseau de Santiago soit
pleinement opérationnel qui puisse
recevoir des fonds je rappelle que des
fonds ont été promis par plusieurs États
membres de l'Union européenne à l'auteur
à hauteur de 25 millions de dollars et
donc là nous serons très attentifs à ce
que ce réseau de Santiago puisse en
effet être véritablement opérationnel au
sortir de la Coop 27 il y a aussi la
question du dialogue de Glasgow sur la
question des pertes préjudices et sur la
question du financement de ces pertes et
préjudices qui a été décidée à Glasgow
sur une durée un dialogue qui est censé
durer jusqu'en 2024 vous savez que les
pays les petites îles en particulier les
pays les plus vulnérables sont très
attachés à la création d'un fond
spécifique pour la question des pertes
et préjudices c'est une question qui
sera à l'ordre du jour et sur laquelle
nous allons travailler nous pensons que
créer un fond n'est peut-être pas la
solution nous avons beaucoup de fonds
actuellement nous avons un fond pour
l'adaptation nous avons fond vert pour
le climat nous avons des fonds pour le
fond pour l'environnement mondial nous
avons un fond spécifique pour les PMA et
donc nous avons tout un paysage qu'on
pourrait
nous pensons pouvoir rationaliser pour
faire face à cette question et puis
aussi il y aura des choses sur la
question des pertes et préjudices qui
devront être présentés de manière très
concrète qu'est-ce qu'on fait
concrètement pour cette question et là
il y a plusieurs pistes qui ont commencé
à être tracés la question de l'alerte
précoce le secrétaire général des
Nations unies au printemps dernier
indiqué que il souhaitait que d'ici 2027
donc d'ici 5 ans l'ensemble des
populations vulnérales vulnérables du
monde entier soit couvertes par un
mécanisme de d'alerte précoce nous
soutenons très fortement cette idée
je rappelle que la France avait été à
l'initiative d'une initiative
baptisée Cruz climat tout risque
à la COP 21 que nous présidons depuis
l'année dernière et jusqu'à la fin de
cette année
et qui vise précisément à fournir des
systèmes d'alerte précoce aux
populations les plus vulnérables nous
avons décidé de doubler notre
contribution à 8 millions d'euros par an
cette
à cette initiative et nous pensons
qu'elle s'inscrit parfaitement dans le
dans la problématique des pertes et
préjudices
il y a également une initiative très
intéressante lancée par la présidence
allemande du G7 qu'on appelle le
bouclier global sur les risques
climatiques le globulshield qui vise à
développer des systèmes assurantiels
pour les populations qui seraient
soumises à des à des aléas climatiques
et nous nous soutenons cette initiative
et nous comptons faire des annonces
là-dessus donc ça ce sont des réponses
qui sont évidemment partielles à la
question des Perses préjudices mais qui
permettent d'avancer de manière très
concrète et on a senti
que ce soit au G7 mais aussi à la à
Kinshasa à la pré-cop qui avait un
intérêt collectif de la part des pays
les plus vulnérables sur ces questions
et nous avons bon espoir de pouvoir
avancer de manière de manière positive
sur sur ces questions
je signalerai enfin que la COP c'est
aussi le lieu de nombreuses initiatives
de tout de tous ordres on se souvient la
cop26
d'initiatives sur lequel nous devrons
porter l'attention pour voir où en est
le suivi que ce soit le
l'engagement sur le méthane le Globo
muffin plage qui avait été lancé par les
États-Unis et l'Union européenne ou plus
d'une centaine de pays dont la France se
sont engagés collectivement à réduire
leurs émissions de 30%
d'ici 2030 par rapport à 2020
ça ce sont des des
enfin c'est une initiative qui permettra
de d'engranger des résultats rapides si
nous arrivons à la mettre en oeuvre il y
avait un engagement important aussi de
12 milliards de dollars en faveur de la
préservation de la forêt tropicale et il
y aura un suivi de ces engagements à la
Coop 26 il y a également vous souvenez
de l'adhésion de la France à la
déclaration sur le soutien public
international pour la transition
énergétique propre où nous nous étions
engagés à mettre fin aux crédit export
pour les énergies fossiles à compter de
la fin 2022 et nous avons nous France
mis en œuvre cette
cette déclaration puisque dans la loi de
finances 2023 il est précisé que nous
mettrons fin effectivement au crédit
export pour l'ensemble des énergies
fossiles dès la fin 2022 et non pas
comme c'était prévu initialement en 2025
pour le gaz pour le pétrole et en 2035
pour le gaz il y aura aussi d'autres
initiatives qui seront lancés à la Coop
et nous nous regardons avec beaucoup
d'attention les initiatives proposées
par la présidence égyptienne qui
commence à nous envoyer des notes de
concept sur ces initiatives très variées
vous avez évoqué Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
en particulier celle sur l'accès à
l'énergie en Afrique qui nous semble
très importantes au regard des chiffres
que vous avez indiqué sur les défis
auxquels l'Afrique est confrontée en
matière d'accès à l'électricité et à
l'énergie de manière générale 600
millions de personnes qui n'ont pas
accès en Afrique à
l'électricité donc nous regardons ça
avec beaucoup de beaucoup d'intérêt
je
rappelle pour finir que l'intérêt de nos
autorités il est manifeste pour cette
Cope puisque comme je l'indiquais en
introduction le président de la
République a indiqué souhaité participer
à cette très importante rendez-vous au
segment des leaders les 7 et 8 novembre
mais nous aurons également de nombreux
ministres qui feront le déplacement à la
cop27 je vous remercie monsieur le
président
merci à vous je vais donner la parole à
mes collègues évidemment la parole à
Guillaume Chevrollier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ambassadeurs
le sujet du changement climatique et un
sujet de préoccupation majeur
aujourd'hui nos concitoyens des
collectivités locales donc il y a
beaucoup d'attentes par rapport à au
Coop notamment et donc vous avez indiqué
que la Coop 27 serait la Coop de la mise
en œuvre donc on met la pression sur sur
ces rendez-vous internationaux
la première question portera sur les
accords sectoriels qui venaient de
l'évoquer d'ailleurs Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur qui ont jalonné la cop26
de Glasgow lutte contre la déforestation
et la dégradation des sols lutte contre
les émissions de méthane réduction
progressive et sortie du charbon faire
des garanties export au combustibles
fossiles accords véhicule zéro émission
ces accords sectoriels ont évidemment
des limites mais ils ont été une des
forces de la cop26 on peut penser à la
Corse sur la fin des garanties exports
aux énergies fossiles qui trouvera donc
en France dans le cadre du projet de loi
de finance
2023 une traduction législative alors ma
question s'adressera à l'ambassadeur
d'Egypte la présidence égyptienne
souhaite-t-elle renouveler cette
pratique des coalitions sectorielles et
peut-on s'attendre à de nouvelles
avancées sur les coalitions créées
l'année dernière notamment
concernant la sortie du charbon qui est
une question clé dans le contexte
énergétique
du moment où le charbon est sollicité
face au manque de gaz russe en
particulier par ailleurs je souhaiterais
revenir sur un accord sectoriel conclu
l'an passé au sujet des émissions de
méthane cet engagement global pour le
méthane visé à réduire les émissions
globales de méthane d'au moins 30 %
d'ici 2030 par rapport à 2020 les
signataires de cet accord ont-ils depuis
intégrer cet engagement dans leur
contribution nationale je rappelle que
trois des cinq plus gros émetteurs de
méthane au monde la Chine l'Inde et la
Russie manquaient à l'appel de cette
coalition l'année dernière peut-on
espérer une évolution de la position de
ces acteurs et là aussi dans le contexte
de la guerre en Ukraine j'aurais pu
globalement une question sur quel impact
de la guerre en Ukraine sur cette cop27
et
quel CDN pour la Russie attendue dans le
cadre de cette cop
et enfin nous étions félicité à
l'occasion de la cop26 du partenariat de
8,5 milliards de dollars conclus entre
les États-Unis les Royaume-Uni la France
l'Allemagne et l'Union européenne pour
accompagner l'Afrique du Sud dans la
transition du charbon vers l'énergie
propre dans les 5 prochaines années des
partenariats de ce type pourrait-il être
conclu avec d'autres pays pendant cette
COP 27 et plus particulièrement avec des
pays africains merci
de répondre à l'issue madame vareyas
depuis
Messieurs les Ambassadeurs je souhaite
vous remercier en premier lieu d'être
venu jusqu'à nous ce matin vous avez
évoqué la situation des pays les plus
vulnérables et à cet égard je voudrais
rappeler que bien que les médias les
très peu relatés le Pakistan a été
victime cet été d'inondation
dévastatrice causée par des pluies de
mousson diluviennes les experts
d'ailleurs attribuent ce phénomène
violent en réchauffement climatique un
tiers de la population du pays est
recouvert soit la superficie du
Royaume-Uni et 1600 morts depuis le mois
de juin bon plus de aujourd'hui dans ce
pays plus de 7 millions de personnes
vivent dans des camps de fortune où
l'eau potable manque les quelques images
que nous avons pu voir
sont très douloureuses cette catastrophe
climatique elle a conduit le secrétaire
général de l'ONU a exhorter les grands
pollueurs de la planète arrêter cette
folie nous le savons cette calamité va
toucher d'autres pays cela même qui
pollue le moins je rappelle que le
Pakistan en fait ne pèse que 0,8% des
émissions mondiales de CO2
la question écologique amène
inéluctablement la question du modèle
économique mondial dominante et à cet
égard le rapport du GIEC confirme bien
que le capitalisme menace la survie de
la planète ça n'est pas moi qui le dis
c'est le GIEC beaucoup d'entreprises
particulièrement dans le gaz et le
pétrole par ailleurs inclut beaucoup de
compensations dans le plan de leur plan
neutralité carbone alors que ces
compensations ne génère aucune réduction
d'émissions substantielles qu'en
pensez-vous
Messieurs les Ambassadeurs quelles
ambitions concrètes portez-vous sur
cette nouvelle Coop 27 quels objectifs
audacieux m'étonnables souhaitez-vous
faire adopter lors de ces négociations
et notamment pour imposer au pays les
plus pollueurs qu'il respectent leurs
engagements qui pour le moment ne
constitue pas des obligations je le
rappelle
merci beaucoup merci Messieurs les
Ambassadeurs pour pour vos interventions
respectives vous y avez fait allusion là
la COP 27 s'inscrit dans un contexte
particulièrement spécifique puisque
elle fait suite au bilan en demi-teinte
de la cop26 dans les engagements pris
ont été jugés insuffisants pour limiter
le réchauffement climatique à 1,5 degrés
et deuxièmement elle intervient après la
publication du sixième rapport du GIEC
qui est sans appel puisque la planète
c'est déjà réchauffé de 1,1 degré et le
seuil de 1,5 degrés par rapport à l'air
pré-industrielle sera atteint en 2030 il
faut réagir c'est ce que vous avez dit
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur Youssef et je
voudrais poser une question un peu
général à notre ambassadeur monsieur
Crouzat ce 6e rapport du GIEC sera-t-il
au cœur des négociations avec notamment
des pistes pragmatiques d'action ou
faut-il être pessimiste comme les notre
ancien président de la République
François Hollande qui il y a quelques
jours déclaré que finalement la Chine a
d'autres préoccupations la Russie n'en
parlons pas les États-Unis sont plutôt
tournés aujourd'hui vers les élections
de novembre avec d'ailleurs un risque de
retour des républicains en congrès qui
sont semblent-ils moins proactifs sur
sur le sujet et sa phrase d'ailleurs est
assez dure puisque il déclarait dans son
propos la semaine dernière il n'y a pas
grand chose à atteindre à attendre
pardon de cette coop l'Europe et le seul
continent qui tient bon mais avec des
entorses assez graves par rapport aux
engagements de Paris alors Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur cruzat votre optimisme
est-il réel ou est-il comment dirais
diplomatique
je vous propose de répondre qui commence
par l'optimisme
merci beaucoup mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs pour ces questions je vais
essayer de peut-être les passer en revue
avant de donner la parole à mon collègue
l'ambassadeur Youssef
sur
les accords sectoriels monsieur le
sénateur en effet il y en a beaucoup et
elles font l'objet il y en a qui sont
dans le cadre des négociations connues
et il y en a qui sont hors du cadre
strict des négociations knuk le méthane
vous avez évoqué les véhicules zéro une
mission tout cela fera l'objet de suivi
une des
un des bénéfices de la de la présidence
britannique de la cop26 c'est que les
Britanniques sont très soucieux de faire
en sorte que ces annonces qui ont été
faites à la Coop 26 soit suivi des faits
et soit suivi de
questions de redevabilité et donc nous
aurons à la COP 27 des discussions en
particulier sur le méthane pour voir
comment les choses avancent sur le
méthane vous avez dit et c'est très
juste que des pays comme l'Inde la Chine
ou la Russie ne sont pas signataires de
ce global time plage je rappelle
toutefois que la Chine avait
annoncé qu'il ferait un effort
particulier avec un plan sur qui
publierait sur sur le méthane et donc
nous suivons ça avec avec attention je
rappelle aussi que les États-Unis sont
un des premiers émetteurs de méthane et
que si et que comme les Etats-Unis font
été un des initiateurs de cette
initiative
on a bon espoir que ils prennent ce
dossier à bras le corps pour pouvoir
trouver des résultats tangibles et
d'ailleurs cette question du méthane
elle sera au coeur aussi de discussion
que nous aurons dans le cadre des
négociations CNC sur la la création de
ce
programme de travail sur l'atténuation
qui a été mandatée à Glasgow et donc
nous devons pouvoir mettre en place ce
programme de travail sur l'atténuation
qui courra jusqu'en 2030 pour
continuer à renforcer l'ambition et la
question du méthane sera évoquée dans ce
programme de travail
sur l'impact de la guerre en Ukraine et
la Russie c'est vrai que la Russie est
un partenaire très important des
négociations climatiques c'est
4% 4 à 5% des émissions mondiales
je rappelle que la Russie a ratifié
l'accord de Paris c'était c'était avant
la question
ukrainienne la guerre en Ukraine c'était
en 2019
mais elle l'a fait mais ça c'était quand
même un très bon signal après
comment
réagira-t-elle sur
dans les négociations ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que dans les
négociations en G20 en particulier la
Russie n'était pas la plus virulente
la Russie était même souvent assez atome
en réalité qu'est-ce que cela
signifiera qu'est-ce qu'on doit en
quelle conclusion doit-on en tirer sur
la manière dont elle se comportera à la
Coop elle-même
c'est à voir vous avez évoqué les
jetpies les just anody transnation
partner ship vous avez évoqué les 8
milliards et demi de dollars que nous
avons
promis collectivement à la l'Afrique du
Sud c'était la France l'Allemagne le
Royaume-Uni les États-Unis et l'Union
européenne c'était un premier
partenariat
assez novateur dans son esprit où l'idée
était que des grands bailleurs se
réunissent de manière coordonnée pour
aider un pays à opérer sa transition et
à se désengager du charbon il y a
développé les énergies renouvelables
nous aurons des choses à faire valoir à
la co27 sur cette question
puisque nous avons avancé depuis la
signature de ce partenariat le jetpi
comme on le comme on le dit en anglais
avec l'Afrique du Sud
la France en particulier et
l'Allemagne sont travail main dans la
main pour avancer sur un projet un prêt
de politique publique au gouvernement
sud-africain qui fera l'objet d'une
annonce à la Coop 27 nous travaillons
actuellement avec d'autres pays pour
essayer de décimer cette idée qui est
prometteuse nous travaillons avec
l'Indonésie avec le Vietnam avec l'Inde
avec le Sénégal également pour dans
l'espoir de pouvoir faire une annonce à
la cop27 une déclaration politique qui
qui montre la volonté commune partagée
des bailleurs
membres du G7 et de ces pays faire
avancer sur leur décarbonation
madame la
sénatrice vous avez évoqué cette
tragédie au Pakistan qui effectivement
est
le signal que nous devons absolument
absolument accélérer les efforts
et trouver les moyens de venir en aide
au pays qui sont soumis à de tels de
tels des astres il y a des moyens qui
ont été mis en œuvre des il y a des des
fonds qui ont été débloqués de postes
postes catastrophes via undr en
particulier la France aussi c'est
mobilisé avec l'envoi de d'avions
humanitaires pour venir en aide au
Pakistan
il y a encore forte à faire et il y aura
fort à faire pour les mois et les années
qui viennent vraisemblablement à la
suite de cette catastrophe terrible vous
avez dit que le quels sont nos objectifs
finalement pour pour rehausser
l'ambition dans le cadre d'un accord qui
il n'y a pas d'obligation alors c'est
vrai que c'est un c'est un sujet qui est
mis sur la table depuis l'origine depuis
la création de l'adoption de l'accord de
Paris
il n'y a certes pas d'obligation comme
il en a pu y avoir sous protocole de
Kyoto où on imposait par le haut des
réductions d'émissions pays là
l'originalité la force et la faiblesse
de l'accord de Paris c'est d'imposer à
tous de participer à cet effort
collectif de réduction d'émissions mais
à la mesure de leurs moyens et à la
mesure de ce qu'ils pensent pouvoir être
le maximum à un moment donné avec
l'obligation pour pour le coup de
rehausser cette ambition tous les 5 ans
c'est une force parce que ça fait que
c'est très inclusif c'est une faiblesse
évidemment parce que
les pays ne décident de même de l'effort
qu'ils vont fournir
en tout cas ce que je peux dire sur
l'accord de Paris c'est que si on
n'avait pas eu l'accord de Paris on
serait aujourd'hui sur des schémas de
d'augmentation de température qui serait
pas compris entre 1,8 et 3 degrés
d'augmentation de température au regard
de l'ensemble des décisions qui ont été
prises par les différents pays mais on
serait plutôt sur une une ligne de 4 5
degrés d'augmentation à l'horizon 2100
ce qui serait absolument inimaginable
monsieur le sénateur vous évoquez je
crois le rapport du GIEC
en effet le rapport du GIEC
seulement essentiel parce que si
finalement la science qui guide les
négociations c'est la science qui depuis
la fin des années 80 nous alerte et nous
alerte de manière de plus en plus
pressante sur les les risques que nous
encourons si nous ne faisons pas assez
qui nous indiquent que nous devons
pendant cette décennie critique faire
tous les efforts nécessaires pour
espérer rester dans la trajectoire je
rappelle que nous avons un budget
carbone pour faire court de 3000
gigatonnes de
d'émissions maximum pour pouvoir rester
dans la
dans une augmentation de 1,5 on a déjà
dépensé depuis le début de leur
industriel
2500 gigatonnes donc il nous reste
grosso modo 500 gigatonnes
à dépenser si je puis dire à émettre
et pas plus donc vraiment la science
elle est absolument claire elle nous
doit être notre boussole et donc on a la
science l'accord de Paris et ce sont ce
sont nos boussoles qui nous permettent
d'avancer
en effet la Chine vous évoquez la Chine
30% des émissions mondiales aujourd'hui
30% et donc si la Chine ne fait pas les
efforts nécessaires
sans la Chine il n'y aura pas de
pas de solution alors c'est vrai que la
Chine elle est extrêmement énergivore
elle continue à dépenser et à augmenter
ses émissions de charbon mais je signale
aussi que la Chine c'est le plus fort
taux d'augmentation des énergies
renouvelables donc c'est un peu le yin
et le yang au sein de la Chine je
rappelle son objectif absolument
spectaculaire de 1200 GW à l'horizon
2030 ce qui est absolument considérable
et elle s'en donne les moyens donc on
espère évidemment qu'elle tiendra son
objectif de pic des émissions avant 2030
et on pense qu'elle est capable de le
faire bien avant 2030 peut-être dès 2025
pour ensuite réduire ses émissions de
manière très rapide puisque elle
renforcer que elle serait à la
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2060 en
2060 ça fait 30 ans pour elle pour la
Chine entre 2030 et 2060 je rappelle que
nous l'Union européenne nous nous
donnons 60 ans pour faire cette
trajectoire de 1990 à 2050 donc le le
défi est extraordinaire pour la Chine
idem pour la pour l'Inde l'Inde 7% des
émissions mondiales
qui a soumis une CDN renforcée cette
année donc elle vous le veut ce qui est
à noter je rappelle que jusqu'à il y a
peu l'Inde se refusait à marquer sa
volonté de réduire les émissions et là
elle a annoncé pour 2070 la neutralité
carbone 2070 ça semble très loin mais
aussi pour la pour l'Inde
c'est un pic d'émission à 2040 une
neutralité donc elle se donne 30 ans
pour faire cela et ça aussi c'est un
défi énorme pour ce pays les États-Unis
enfin
et les élections mitormes tomberont le
premier mardi de la Coop donc elle
donneront une saveur particulière sans
doute à cette coque en fonction des
résultats ce qui est certain en tout cas
c'est que avec le plan américain qui est
finalement passé au congrès de 369
milliards de dollars de flèche
qui est consacré en fait à la lutte pour
le pour la lutte contre le changement
climatique les Américains pensent que
ils pourront
réduire leurs émissions de 40% à
l'horizon 2030 par rapport à 2005 40% ce
n'est pas tout à fait encore ce qui
avait indiqué le président Biden qui
avait annoncé 50 à 52%
mais les Américains je pense sont
déterminés d'abord à faire le plus vite
possible il recrute par milliers des
agents pour dépenser ces 369 milliards
dans les deux années qui viennent donc
quel que soit la prochaine
administration les choses auront
beaucoup beaucoup avancé on est dans le
cadre d'une loi et donc une loi c'est
difficile à remettre en cause puisque on
sait que le président américain dispose
d'un droit de veto et ils ont aussi la
ferme volonté d'avancer sur des
réglementations nouvelles notamment de
l'agence pour l'environnement pour
pouvoir combler ce ce delta de 10 à 12%
qui leur manque pour atteindre leur
objectif
merci monsieur le président
merci Président je veux pas répéter
beaucoup de choses qui ont été déjà
dites par mon ami et mon collègue
Stéphane crusat mais je voulais juste
bon dire sur quelques points d'abord sur
les accords sectoriels bien sûr tout le
sujet qui ont été évoqué et on la coupe
de Glasgow Pentecôte
en plus pas seulement dans le knuc mais
aussi la présidence il est sienne de la
COP va organiser des journées
thématiques par exemple il y aura une
journée sur la décarbonisation il y aura
un autre journée sur les financement
journée des sciences une journée des
jeunes et des futurs génération une
journée sur le genre
une journée d'adaptation des agriculture
une journée sur l'eau
biodiversité société civile bien sûr
et en plus l'Egypte aussi balancer
plusieurs initiatives iront cette COP
qui qui
mettra des solutions pour plusieurs
défis qui font face actuellement
la communauté internationale par exemple
je pense je voulais vous partager avec
vous une initiative sur une vie descente
qui vise à améliorer la qualité de vie
dans les espaces ruraux en Afrique une
initiative sur les systèmes d'alerte
précoce dans le cadre de soutien ni
initiative de sextage général de l'ONU
une initiative sur l'alimentation des
changements climatiques
une autre sur l'eau la transition
énergétique en Afrique
sur le Moyen-Orient aussi il y aura une
initiative qui qui
va qui vise à soutenir les efforts des
pays pour faire face à la dégradation
des prairies de promouvoir l'action
climatique
madame la sénatrice vous avez parlé
aussi vous avez tout à fait raison des
inondations de en Pakistan c'est un
phénomène à côté des autres phénomènes
comme la sécheresse comme les les feux
dans les forêts c'est des phénomènes qui
malheureusement les pays dans des
quelques pays on va développement
surtout en Afrique en face et c'est pour
ça que j'ai dit cette tombe de réagir
malheureusement
beaucoup de peuples dans le monde entier
qui souffrent énormément de scènes
phénomènes je reste toujours très
optimiste et je garde toujours partie
plein de la verte mais mais quelquefois
si la volonté politique qui qui à la fin
qui qui qui dépend de la décision des
CPI et grandes puissances et là sur les
grandes puissances je voulais vous dire
que l'Égypte a commencé depuis début de
l'année des contacts avec la Chine avec
les avec aussi quelques pays asiatiques
afin de préparer pour cette coque là
nous nous réalisons bien sûr que ces
questions très difficiles mais nous
aussi nous estimons que ces temps de
faire des compromis de d'essayer de
répondre aux engagements de tous et de
aussi de de
d'essayer d'accommoder les les
inquiétudes des engagements et en bas on
imparnira aucun effort de continuer dans
dans
ce domaine là surtout à demander aux
grandes puissances de respecter leur
engagements
dans le domaine des changements
climatique merci
merci je donne la parole à Monsieur gold
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ambassadeurs ma question fait suite à la
pré cop27 qui s'est déroulée à Kinshasa
la semaine dernière parmi les sujets qui
ont été soulevés par les pays en voie de
développement lors de cette réunion des
changes il est la question légitime des
efforts demandés à ces étapes notamment
africains qui sont peu émetteurs de gaz
à effet de serre à l'échelle mondiale
mais qui en même temps ont besoin des
énergies fossiles et de l'exploitation
de leurs ressources naturelles pour
accélérer leur développement
alors dans ces cas là
peut être difficile de jongler entre la
lutte contre le changement climatique et
la lutte contre la pauvreté leurs
besoins court terme pouvant aller à
contre-courant des objectifs
internationaux de réduction des gaz à
effet de serre alors puisque vous êtes
là aujourd'hui moi j'aimerais savoir
comment est perçu le discours des pays
industrialisés dans les négociations
internationales et comment adapter ce
discours pour rendre acceptable et même
audible les efforts que l'on demande à
des pays et des populations moins
favorisées
merci Monsieur Houlgate merci monsieur
le Président merci Monsieur les
ambassadeurs en tant que membres du
groupe d'amitié français-egypte je salue
plus particulièrement donc la présence
votre présence est excellence et puis
vous remercier aussi de votre
implication et j'irai de
des efforts que vous faites notamment
donc au niveau pour répondre à nos
sollicitations au niveau du groupe du
groupe d'amitié je voudrais souligner un
fait aussi c'est que je crois que
l'Égypte peut s'enorgueillir
d'accueillir cette cop27 puisque déjà en
2018 elle avait accueilli donc la 14e
conférence sur la biodiversité vous
l'avez souligné excellence que que cette
Cope sera une opportunité de mettre le
point sur les priorités des pays en
développement et plus particulièrement
sur les besoins de l'Afrique puisque
l'Afrique est un délai continent qui est
les plus affectés par la question du
changement climatique alors que ça a été
déjà été dit c'est
considéré comme étant le moins
responsable et celui qui émet le moins
je voudrais peut-être aussi dans un
autre domaine et de façon très
complémentaire renvoyer au rapport qui a
été fait sur les inégalités mondiales et
ce rapport sur les inégalités mondiales
dit d'une façon globale que 10 % des
plus riches sont responsables de 48 %
des émissions et si on raisonne par zone
géographique vous l'avez dit l'Afrique
elle ne représente que que 3%
la Conférence ministérielle africaine
sur l'environnement qui qui sait réunit
à Dakar donc je dirais unanimement
mis en avant la nécessité de reconnaître
les besoins notamment les besoins en
financement il y a eu une déclaration
sur le fait d'abandonner les modèles de
développement à forte intensité de
combustible fossiles néanmoins donc se
pose et je prolonge là la question de de
Monsieur gold il néanmoins donc un
certain nombre de pays
ont affirmé ne pas vouloir renoncer à
l'exploitation de leurs ressources en
pétrole et en gaz le Sénégal prévoit
notamment de commencer à exploiter ses
réserves de gaz et de pétrole dans
l'Atlantique et ça dès 2023 de même la
République démocratique du Congo a lancé
donc des appels d'offres pour
l'exploitation de 27 blocs pétroliers et
3 et 3 gaziers donc bien évidemment les
porte-paroles de de ces pays disent que
ils jugent que c'est complètement
inconcevable que l'Occident qui a
construit son industrie grâce à
l'énergie fossile demande à des pays
donc d'y renoncés alors que ces pays
les pays occidentaux représentent
l'écrasante majorité donc des émissions
donc la question voilà comment arriver à
réconcilier ces injonctions
contradictoires entre la nécessité
d'avoir des ressources pour le
développement et on sait que beaucoup de
pays africains tirent leurs ressources
de depuis l'exploitation du gaz et du
Pétrole et puis le nécessaire lutte
contre le changement climatique
merci on va poursuivre avec Madame
privil et puis je vais aller jusqu'au
bout puisque nous autres ont des
rendez-vous également qu'on puisse
terminer vers 11h10 merci
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ambassadeurs merci d'être avec nous pour
échanger c'est très précieux alors je
voulais revenir d'abord sur cette coop
Charmel cheikh qui sera comme 27 la Coop
de la mise en oeuvre voilà qui est très
ambitieux et je voulais d'abord vous
interroger sur la diplomatie que vous
allez mener auprès des pays qui ne
s'engagent pas suffisamment vous nous en
avez un peu parlé mais dites nous
peut-être un petit peu plus et également
parce que comme vous l'avez mentionné
les gaz à effet de serre n'ont pas cessé
d'augmenter or nous inscrivons au fur et
à mesure depuis des années déjà des
objectifs de diminution donc le
questionnement il est à un moment et
peut-être ce sera peut-être celui de
cette coque là ne faut-il pas pousser un
grand cri d'alarme
justement sur le fait que nous devons
absolument avancer sur ce sujet là
et à ce sujet je voudrais rappeler que
par le réchauffement climatique que nous
sommes en train de subir il a des
boucles rétroactives qui se mettent en
place c'est à dire les calculs que nous
faisons et le captage du carbone qui se
fait dans les forêts dans les océans est
par rapport à un état du monde qui est
celui actuel mais avec le réchauffement
que nous subissons notamment avec la
perte du vivant dans les océans le puits
de carbone des océans ne sera plus aussi
efficace les forêts non plus parce que
les follets les forêts quand elles
subissent des sécheresses perdent leurs
feuilles ne font plus le même captage de
carbone donc on a effectivement à
salarmer beaucoup de ce qui est en train
de se passer et de ces boucles
rectroactives qui se mettent en place et
particulièrement aussi par rapport aux
méthane les fentes qui sont en train de
se passer du pergélisol vont dégager du
méthane qu'il a ne dû à aucune activité
humaine et qui sera le résultat du
réchauffement climatique donc c'est
signal d'alarme qu'il faudrait lancer
sur cette chose là et après je voudrais
revenir sur la juste répartition de la
responsabilité ce qu'il faut que nous
ayons en tête c'est que nous les pays
développés nous avons contribué à ce qui
est en train de d'exister là c'est à
dire le réchauffement que nous vivons
les pays en voient de développement
n'ont pas contribué à ça et donc nous
avons une responsabilité pas seulement
de ce que nous émettons en ce moment
mais de ce que nous avons émis par le
passé donc nous avons une responsabilité
accrue supplémentaire à celle de ces
pays-là et je pense que les choses
seraient bien mieux vécues et notamment
par les pays en voie développement si
nous étions capables de reconnaître
cette responsabilité là et de la mettre
en oeuvre et de la mettre en œuvre
quelque part
nos engagements voilà merci
j'avais initialement deux questions
mais la première concernée les moyens à
louer par les pays riches au pays les
plus pauvres je crois que le sujet a été
épuisé fort justement d'ailleurs par les
remarques de mes collègues et par vos
réponses aussi je me consacrerai à la
deuxième question qui concerne les
grands événements écossides puisque
lorsque la Coupe du monde de football a
été décidée en 2010 au Qatar elle a
suscité des protestations mais pas à la
mesure de la gravité de l'événement
puisque le réchauffement climatique
s'est accéléré depuis et qu'on ne
soupçonnait pas à l'époque combien de
milliers de morts 7 et cet événement
et donc a posteriori il y a maintenant
beaucoup de réactions je crois que la
première ministre a dit qu'elle ne se
rendrait pas au Qatar et également si je
prends l'exemple de ma ville à Lille la
mère de Lille a décidé de ne pas
retransmettre les événements sur écran
géants comme on a coutume de le faire
dans la ville mais néanmoins et et de
manière absolument irrationnelle et
incompréhensible de grands événements
sont annoncés qui vont avoir lieu
pratiquement dans les mêmes conditions
et pour ne pas le citer cet événement
qui va se dérouler en Arabie Saoudite
c'est absolument incompréhensible et je
me demandais si la COP ne pouvait pas
être le lieu puisque vous disiez qu'il y
avait des initiatives d'une initiative
pour protester ou demander que de tels
événements n'est plus lieu à l'heure où
nous connaissons cette accélération du
réchauffement climatique merci
merci chers collègues madame sain p
merci monsieur le Président merci
Messieurs les Ambassadeurs pour
vos témoignages devant nous ce matin
j'aurais deux petites deux petites
questions dans le alors tout en
reconnaissant les objectifs louables de
la COP 27 bien entendu
ne pensez-vous pas monsieur monsieur
Crozat Monsieur l'Ambassadeur cruzat que
j'ai envie de dire la crise actuelle
nous rattrape rattrape la France et à
l'heure où nous sommes obligés de
rechercher des des énergies coûte que
coûte et nous recherchons du gaz et nous
recherchons du charbon ne pensez-vous
pas et ne craignez-vous pas que la
France soit actuellement et lors de
cette COP 27 qu'elle soit en
contradiction avec les annonces de la
COP 27 et deuxièmement ne pensez-vous
pas qu'on risque de perdre de la
crédibilité sur le terrain climatique
vis-à-vis des pays en voie de
développement donc quel sera le langage
notre langage quel sera le langage de la
France vu cette actualité
galopante qui nous rattrape et qui peut
peut-être nous mettre en contradiction
avec les grandes principes que nous
avons déjà évoqué et que nous évoquerons
la cop27 je vous remercie merci Monsieur
Dantec
le Président je crois qu'il faut dire
que dans un monde en guerre c'est quand
même difficile de trouver un accord
global sur le sur le climat
donc c'est une COP un petit peu entre
parenthèses en attendant de savoir dans
quel monde on sera dans deux ou trois
ans donc il ne faut pas demander la
présidente égyptienne
l'impossible dans ce contexte
international je crois que ce qui s'est
passé au G20
en difficulté donc d'abord bon courage à
la présidence égyptienne dans dans ce
monde extrêmement complexe alors
néanmoins toutes les cops sont utiles et
permettent d'avancer sur un certain
nombre de secteur moi je pense
qu'effectivement je crois que la
présidence égyptienne le souhaitait
c'est quand même une COP développement
et climat clairement et développement de
l'Afrique donc avec la question
récurrente extrêmement importante des
financements mais je pense que derrière
derrière cette question il y a toujours
un peu une question de de contrat entre
l'Afrique et le reste du monde ou entre
l'Afrique et les pays développés donc je
voulais interroger Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur sur ce point pour savoir
qu'est-ce que l'Afrique de son côté mais
sur la table
au-delà d'un discours juste sur le fait
que la prime n'est pas historiquement
responsable de la situation il s'agit
aussi de voir probablement affirmer le
chèque ce que l'Afrique propose soit en
captation de carbone ça assez présent à
Kinshasa après Coop là la semaine
dernière avec la question du prix du
carbone par exemple de compensation qui
sera certainement sur la table mais
aussi qu'est-ce que la prix l'Afrique et
je me permets de sortir d'un discours
par trop policier qu'est-ce que
l'Afrique propose en terme déficience de
ses propres actions on sait la
difficulté d'accès aux financement pour
beaucoup de projets une décentralisation
trop faible un accès aux réseaux pour
les énergies renouvelables dans des
systèmes là aussi très centralisés qui
ne sont pas efficients il y a aussi des
blocages africains à se développements
qui font partie du sujet et donc ma
première question est vraiment là-dessus
de savoir vers quel contrat peut-on
aller qu'est-ce que l'Afrique de son
côté mais sur la table ce qui n'enlève
rien à la nécessité d'augmenter les
financements venant des des pays les
plus développés donc ça c'est la
première question et là la deuxième là
aussi ne pas être trop long c'est que
c'est la première année depuis longtemps
on a trois cops la même année on a eu la
COP des certifications à Abidjan on a
donc la COP par Charles sec et on sera
ensuite à Montréal
l'idée qu'il fallait une convergence
entre les trois coqs nés de nedrio des
trois conventions des drio était assez
présents dans le discours c'est ces
dernières années c'était vraiment monté
mais on a un peu on tarde un peu on voit
la réalisation c'est-à-dire au-delà d'un
discours un peu global il faut une
convergence des trois-cops quels vont
être à charme Cheikh et par la
présidente égyptienne les actes concrets
qui amènent effectivement à cette
convergence et le fait d'intégrer
effectivement beaucoup plus les enjeux
de biodiversité dans les dans les
stratégies climat et peut-être quand
même troisième question monsieur
l'ambassadeur français qui est que dans
ce cette situation de crise économique
est-ce que malgré tout dans les
les différents échanges qui ont lieu
aujourd'hui
il y a une conscience des pays
occidentaux qui vont devoir mettre plus
d'argent sur la table ou est-ce que face
au niveau de crise économique vers où on
est ou en tout cas vers lequel on va
est-ce qu'il y a là quand même
maintenant beaucoup beaucoup de prudence
sur de nouveaux engagements financiers
de la part des pays les plus riches
merci chers collègues monsieur devinez
[Musique]
merci Monsieur Bigot
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ambassadeurs vous nous avez indiqué que
cette cops serait la COP de la mise en
œuvre traditionnellement les cops sont
toujours consensuelles et sont utiles
mais celles-ci intervient dans un
contexte particulier lié à des tensions
mondiales qui nous amène à revoir notre
fonctionnement de nos économies et puis
également ça a été souligné par un
certain nombre de mes collègues par un
certain nombre de dispositions qui vont
concerner l'ensemble de la planète et de
ce point de vue nous ne sommes pas tous
égaux devant le dérèglement climatique
entre pays émergents et pays
industrialisés
je voudrais d'abord traiter le premier
point les tensions internationales nous
ont amenés notamment à avoir une des
tensions sur les approvisionnements en
énergie dans nos sociétés qui mettent en
évidence la responsabilité climatique
des pays en guerre c'est bien le conflit
à l'heure actuelle en Europe de l'Est
qui nous amène à avoir des des décisions
politiques
qui ont des impacts sur le climat qui
qui résultent de de ces de ces tensions
un exemple nous avons voté
nous on l'a pas voté mais les
centrale méthanier au large du Havre
pour accueillir du gaz de schiste on va
remettre en fonctionnement des centrales
à charbon donc la responsabilité des
pays en guerre est clairement à pointer
dans
l'aggravation de du dérèglement
climatique est-ce que la cop27 peut déjà
pointer du doigt le fait que les
conflits
des conflits nous amène à des
régressions y compris sur le plan
climatique le deuxième point c'est que
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure ça a été
excellent dit par un certain nombre de
mes collègues les pays envoient de
développement mesurent que pour eux
quand on leur parle d'atténuation à la
limite eux ils comprennent provocation
c'est à dire que ce sont des pays qui
sont peu émetteurs de gaz à effet de
serre qui ont un niveau de développement
qui parfois a besoin pour se financer
des énergies fossiles je pense notamment
au Congo qui est assis sur des nappes
pétrolières importantes leur demander
demain de se priver des moyens de leur
développement c'est presque provocateur
donc traditionnellement les cops ont
toujours un langage diplomatique et
consensuel mais là je crois qu'il va
falloir
transgresser les codes et parler d'une
manière plus directe pointer les
responsabilités les risques sont connus
il va falloir prendre des décisions
incitatives peut-être et en tout cas
vous l'avez mentionné il faut une
volonté politique c'était vos propos à
tous les deux
de ce point de vue est-ce que vous
pensez qu'une COP qui se termine par un
constat s'il le faut divergence entre
les acteurs mais qui pointent les
responsabilités qui pointent des
clivages est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est quelque chose qui peut faire
avancer la cause je vous remercie merci
la parole est à Monsieur Favreau
je suis le président ma question très
brève s'adresse à Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
Youssef Monsieur l'Ambassadeur vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure qu'à Charmel
Cheikh vous organisiez différents
ateliers et si j'ai bien compris vous
avez évoqué un atelier sur sur le genre
je vous demande quel est le lien qui
existe entre le dérèglement climatique
et la thématique du genre
merci et chers collègues j'ai donné la
parole à Monsieur je n'ai
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ambassadeurs merci effectivement pour
vos exposés également les réponses que
vous avez déjà apportées sur le contexte
et les enjeux de cette cop27 sur le
réchauffement climatique et les moyens
de le limiter au-delà des
impératifs de sobriété sobriété qui est
une nouvelle vertu moderne et
qu'on va même avoir vos impératifs
horaires je serai donc bref et
synthétique le plus sobre possible mais
en illustration de ce qui a déjà été dit
par mes collègues sur l'exemple de la
République démocratique du Congo je
voudrais peut-être citer deux chiffres
la RDC avait signé à la cop26 un accord
de 500 millions d'euros
l'engageant à préserver ses forêts mais
comme ça a été dit fin juillet le
gouvernement congolais a lancé un appel
d'offres pour l'octroi de droit à
l'exploitation à 27 champs pétroliers et
trois champs gaziers et c'est là où je
veux en venir il estime le gain
potentiel à plus de 640 milliards
d'euros
lorsqu'on rapproche les deux montants
effectivement ça illustre bien la
difficulté et donc ma question est la
suivante après le poids des mots il y a
bien sûr le choc des montants financiers
est-ce que vous pensez que la cop27 sera
même de résoudre cette équation
merci
merci beaucoup monsieur Président
je remercie toutes les sénatrices et les
sénateurs pour leur question
pertinente je peux grouper ces questions
dans quatre axes principaux premièrement
l'Afrique
plusieurs questions ont touché les
questions n'auront évoqué la question
d'Afrique je voulais vous dire tout
d'abord que pour l'Égypte c'est un c'est
une copie africaine puisque
on va obtenir dans dans sur le continent
africain sur le sol africain et c'est
pour ça que l'Egypte a fixé une de leurs
prix de ses priorités le continent
africain et comment on peut aider les
pays africains dans leur lutte contre le
changement climatique et les phénomènes
des vestatrices qui malheureusement ont
touché plusieurs pays africains comme
j'ai dit dans mes propos trois le
continent africain est responsable de 3%
seulement des émissions malheureusement
sont c'est le continent le plus touché
c'est pour ça et là je répondrai une
autre question aussi sur qu'est-ce que
l'Afrique présente l'autre côté
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que l'Afrique a
présenté à part les CDN les
contributions
déterminées au niveau national qui ont
été annoncés par plusieurs pays
africains le continent aussi les pays
africains ont lancé plusieurs
initiatives pour encourager surtout la
l'adaptation et surtout dans le domaine
par exemple
l'échange des dettes par exemple qui
pourraient aussi fournir de financement
aux clients africains dont le domaine de
et aussi dans le domaine de transition
énergétique qui est une priorité
maintenant pour les pays africains
il y aura aussi un autre initiative qui
va être lancée par le continent africain
concernant le gris national gadget les
les budget vers aussi des des quelques
quelques idées qui pourra encourager et
puis développer à soutenir et à financer
plusieurs projets dans le continent
africain le deuxième axe que je voulais
parler c'est concernant les efforts
diplomatiques
comme vous l'avez dit c'est très
difficile
de cette COP bien sûr surtout dans le
contexte international actuel c'est très
difficile mais
si tu as une tâche qu'on va continuer à
assumer au fond et on va continuer à
parler à tous les pays surtout les
groupes puissances même les petits les
les petits pays les surtout les îles
dans les Caraïbes qui aussi de Caraïbes
et dans les pacifiques qui souffrent
énormément aussi de de phénomènes des
changements climatiques on va essayer
d'accommoder tout le monde on va essayer
d'avoir une approche équilibrée qui qui
essaye de trouver des compromis la
diplomatie égyptienne comme on m'a dit
il y a deux jours et connu de trouver de
compromis j'avoue aussi c'est une tâche
très difficile de trouver un compromis
sur les questions de Cop mais on va
donner tous les forts nécessaires pour
essayer à parler et trouver des
solutions surtout avec les grandes
puissances pour les encourager à honorer
leurs engagements déjà prises troisième
point concernant les malheureusement
madame la sénatrice est parti sur les
protestations qui peuvent avoir lieu
durant la Coop bien sûr il y aura une
zone pour se protester comme c'est passé
durant les différentes cops et bien sûr
la partie civile aussi va être présente
et va participer activement dans les
travaux de la prochaine COP dernière
pense sur les questions de genre les
questions de genre a été toujours
discutées durant les réunions de Coop et
maintenant c'est devenu aussi comment on
dit en anglais crosscating c'est c'est
un sujet en commun qui est discuté dans
toutes les instances onusiennes et
internationales c'est pour ça que
l'Egypte vu l'importance donné par le
gouvernement égyptien pour les questions
d'émancipation des femmes surtout on a
pensé que ce sera un élément très
important de
[Musique]
dever une journée
complète pour les questions de genre
merci monsieur le président
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur merci
beaucoup mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs pour toutes ces
questions
il y en a beaucoup et j'essaierai de
faire justement de manière un peu
groupée toute une réflexion que vous
avez
indiqué sur en fait sur sur la question
des de la responsabilité je crois que
c'était madame la sénatrice qui parlait
de juste répartition des responsabilités
c'est en effet un sujet très important
qui qui monte dans les négociations
climatiques qui et on entend des pays
qui sont particulièrement éloquents sur
le sujet l'un en particulier qui nous
dit l'un c'est 7% des émissions
mondiales mais qui nous dit attendez
nous on est à 1,6
tonnes d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre par habitant quand les États-Unis
sont à peu près 10 fois plus et on est
largement de ça de la moyenne mondiale
donc certes on a des émissions de de
7% globale mais
rapporte aux émissions par habitant on
est très très en deçà et donc
poursuivent les Indiens nous on a droit
je reviens à cette histoire de de
partage du gâteau
vous payez développer vous avez dépensé
2500 faux
Gigaton depuis les débuts de la
industriel pour votre développement
il faudrait que vous fassiez les efforts
nécessaires le plus rapidement possible
pour réduire pour que nous nous
puissions bénéficier pour une part de de
ce gâteau et concourir à notre
développement donc on est dans cette
discussion qui est difficile et qui qui
je le répète est de plus en plus
présente dans les négociations on l'a
beaucoup entendu à bonnes cette question
d'équité de responsabilité historique
sujet qui est très sensible parce que la
responsabilité historique juste pour
pour mémoire quand on fait les calculs
et il y a eu un une étude qui a été fait
très intéressante à laquelle je vous
renvoie de carbone action tracker qu'on
trouve sur leur site internet
qui essaie de voir quelles étaient les
responsabilités historique des
différents pays
sans surprise les Américains les
États-Unis représentent à peu près le
quart des émissions historiques
mondiales c'est-à-dire que sur cette
part du gâteau que j'évoquais depuis le
début de leur industriel les États-Unis
on en ont mangé le quart mais on a un
pays comme la Chine dont la
responsabilité historique monte sans
cesse qui est aujourd'hui à peu près 11%
de responsabilité historique mondiale et
ce chiffre ne cesse d'augmenter à mesure
que les émissions des pays développés
diminue c'est à dire comme comme je vous
l'ai rappelé les émissions de la Chine
continuent à augmenter elles atteindront
à pic avant 2030 selon les autorités
chinoises mais au fur et à mesure
qu'elle monte et que nos propres
émissions la France depuis 1990 et
l'Union européenne les États-Unis depuis
2005 réduisent leur émission ça veut
dire que dans dans le dans cette dans
cette répartition de la responsabilité
historique les les émissions de la Chine
augmentent de plus en plus donc il y a
des pays en développement dit en
développement qui font partie du G77 et
de la Chine qui sont parfois un peu
gênés et carbone action tracker aussi à
sortir des chiffres tout à fait
étonnants sur les émissions historiques
par exemple de pays comme le Brésil et
l'Inde qui représentent plus de 4%
respectivement pour chacun de ces deux
pays du fait de la déforestation
etc donc c'est un sujet qui est
extrêmement important mais qui n'est pas
aussi univoque que on veut bien le dire
alors ceci dit et ça renvoie aussi aux
nombreuses questions que vous avez
posées sur sur les demandes
légitimes de pays en développement et en
particulier d'Afrique dont le continent
représente à peine plus de 3% des
émissions de développer leur ressources
fossiles on est en discussion
actuellement avec le Sénégal précisément
dans le cadre avec le Sénégal que nous
essayons de mettre en place d'ici là la
cop27 pour voir comment on peut
réconcilier
l'idée d'une d'un développement que les
Sénégalais souhaitent faire ils parlent
d'un développement sur leurs deux jambes
c'est à dire un développement fondé sur
le gaz dont ils ont découvert de
nombreux ressources mais aussi sur les
énergies renouvelables parce qu'ils ont
bien conscience et tout le monde en a
conscience que ces énergies fossiles
peuvent être une énergie de transition
d'appoint très utile pour le
développement mais ce n'est pas une une
énergie d'avenir et ça on le sait tous
le charbon c'est de plus en plus
difficile aujourd'hui pour n'importe
quel état de trouver des financements
pour la construction d'une centrale à
charbon parce que de nombreuses
investisseurs investisseurs
institutionnels se rendent compte qu'ils
ne veulent pas se retrouver avec des
actifs échoués
qui fait que dans quelques décennies
et bien les énergies fossiles qu'on le
veuille ou non seront des énergies du
passé et donc pour revenir à cette
question compliquée de de l'articulation
entre une volonté de se développer et
une et la nécessité de développer les
énergies renouvelables oui on peut
considérer que certains pays peuvent
dans le cadre d'une transition
réfléchie et qui doit s'inscrire dans
une trajectoire de réduction des
émissions à terme à un horizon déterminé
que ce soit 2050 2060 puisse faire appel
à leurs énergies fossiles
et c'est le cas en particulier
précisément du Sénégal qui est un cas
d'école si je puis dire mais que dans le
même temps il faut que ces pays
développent de manière massive leurs
énergies renouvelables qui sont
aujourd'hui les énergies les énergies
les moins chères je rappelle la chute
vertigineuse du soleil dans la décennie
passée qui a dont les coûts de
production ont dim de 89% et cette
baisse se poursuit donc aujourd'hui
l'énergie la plus la plus
la meilleure marché c'est le solaire et
puis les liens
madame la sénatrice vous évoquez aussi
cette contradiction que qui peut être
perçu entre les
annonces des pays intenstalisés sur le
fait qu'il faut des carbonées et la
réalité d'aujourd'hui je peux simplement
vous donner l'exemple de notre pays nous
avons certes ouvert une centrale à
charbon pour pouvoir faire face à une
demande dans un contexte très difficile
d'approvisionnement énergétique je
rappelle toutefois que le charbon ça
représente moins de 1% de notre mix
électrique et que cette ouverture
temporaire de la centrale elle est
précisément temporaire et que
toutes les émissions de cette centrale à
charbon sont compensées par des actions
donc de reboisement ou de compensation
de gaz à effet de serre et que ont tout
état de cause c'est perçu mais de
manière absolument claire et claire et
nette comme quelque chose de une sorte
de sparadrap pour pouvoir faire face à
une à une une demande de court terme
à moyen et long terme
on est déterminé
France et Union européenne a opéré cette
transition énergétique et la crise que
nous connaissons elle elle nous
encourage à accélérer cette ambition il
n'est que d'entendre la le discours sur
l'état de l'Union de de Madame
Ursula van Verlaine la présidente de la
Commission européenne il y a il y a
quelques semaines qui étaient absolument
limpide sur ce point c'est à dire que la
volonté de l'Union européenne c'est
d'accélérer la transition c'est de
passer à 40% d'énergie renouvelables
d'ici 2030 voire davantage si les
préconisations du du Parlement européen
sont suivis et en tout état de cause
donc de d'accélérer cette cette
transition
voilà j'espère ne rien avoir oublié mais
n'hésitez pas à me
ah oui en effet la convergence des trois
conventions monsieur le sénateur vous
avez tout à fait raison nous sommes dans
une conjonction inédite en fait de trois
coques
issus de la de la du Sommet de la Terre
de Rio
des conventions ici du Sommet de la
Terre de Rio qui auront lieu cette année
celles sur la diversité biologique aura
lieu à Montréal en décembre une un
rendez-vous extrêmement important que
l'on compare souvent au rendez-vous de
la COP 21 pour le climat puisqu'il
s'agit de dresser un nouveau cadre
stratégique pour les prochaines années
pour la protection de la biodiversité et
là on voit qu'il y a en effet énormément
de convergence je ne donnerai qu'un
exemple c'est l'initiative que nous
avons lancée avec le Costa Rica sur la
haute ambition la coalition de la haute
ambition pour la nature et les peuples
qui vise à protéger à faire en sorte que
le maximum de pays et on est plus d'une
centaine aujourd'hui
s'engage à protéger par des
des espaces projets de TG donc la
Constitution d'espace protégés la terre
et les mers qui sont de leur de leur
ressort et donc arriver à 30% de
protection de de des mers et des terres
nous y sommes nous y sommes à peu près
en France et c'est quelque chose que qui
est particulièrement porteur si je puis
dire puisque c'est quelque chose que
nous allons
évoquer à la cop27 mais que nous
évoquerons également à la coque 15
puisque ça il y a des bénéfices
évidemment pour le climat et pour la
biodiversité je rappelle enfin que le
lived qui est complètement aligné que
toutes ces actions sont alignées sur les
objectifs de l'accord de Paris consacre
la moitié de ces financements à des
actions pour le climat que ce soit pour
l'adaptation ou pour l'atténuation et
consacre
et à l'ambition et d'ailleurs il est
presque de consacrer 100% de ces actions
climat a des actions qui ont des co
bénéfices biodiversité donc cette
interaction elle est elle est très
sentie et un dernier point c'est le
projet emblématique de la Grande
muraille verte cette initiative qui vise
à restaurer les sols à développer les
emplois sur toute la bande sahélienne
pour stopper les
la progression du désert dans cette
bande sahélienne qui couvre toute la
toute la latitude de La l'Afrique une
très belle initiative que portée par le
Président de la République au one Planet
sommet sur la biodiversité en
particulier que nous avons évoqué à la
cop26 autour du président de la
République doté de 12 milliards d'euros
où nous davantage d'ailleurs je crois
même et qui est justement un projet tout
à fait emblématique de cette de cette
synergie en fait entre
protection du climat protection de la
diversité de la biodiversité et lutte
contre la désertification merci beaucoup
il y a un monsieur les ambassadeurs je
tiens à vous adresser mais
pour cette ce moment d'échange important
qui a permis effectivement de vous poser
l'ensemble des questions et des réponses
que vous avez apportées merci pour cette
collaboration et on aura l'occasion
effectivement d'échanger par visio sur
la COP et puis une délégation ira
la COP 15 au Canada
le
ils sont une délégation 3 3 sénateurs se
rendra donc à la coupe 15 et j'espère
qu'on aura l'occasion d'échanger
directement à la COP 15 merci